um
[Música]
todos estamos muy emocionados de ver este gran
corazón latiendo en este ser humano
este gran corazón se ha desempeñado muy
bien hasta ahora
incluso más allá de nuestras expectativas no hemos
visto ningún signo de rechazo
simplemente no quería morir
no  quería morir
y
sintió que si no tenía la oportunidad
y estaba bastante convencido por
varios médicos que le habían dicho que tenía
una enfermedad mortal y que era poco probable que
dejara el hospital por eso con
eso como antecedente como
alternativa  él me dijo dos
cosas muy importantes dijo que no quiero
morir
y dijo que si lo hago
quizás
aprendas algo para ayudar a otros
[Música]
así que el motor de todo esto fue
brindar una oportunidad  para pacientes con
enfermedad cardíaca en etapa terminal que no pudieron
calificar o simplemente no obtuvieron un
corazón a tiempo
para tratar
su función cardíaca realmente deficiente con un
trasplante
[Música]
tú